so at 30 I started Wine Library TV
YouTube blows up at 31 I'm on Conan
O'Brien Ellen there's articles being
written about me now they're writing
that the business grew from three to
sixty million dollars in sales I'm
becoming this guy I got so many goddamn
emails from friends in high school
during that period when I was showing up
in all these magazines and TV shows and
every single one of them was like hey
Gary you remember me from high school oh
my god
you're so lucky I wrote back every
single one of them and said let me just
clarify one thing I'm not lucky I worked
I worked every goddamn weekend at every
holiday since I was 14 years old so you
can keep that luck [ __ ] in your pocket
every day every day that I live my life
I get five to twenty seven emails from
people that are telling me that they are
quitting or they should quit or or are
really coming to me as a last resort to
convince them not to quit I think a lot
of times or or maybe give them
confirmation that they should quit you
know hey Gary this is Sally I've been
doing my blog now for nine months and
I'm not getting the results that I like
to see or that I was promised or that
you and you end Oh should I give up like
you know should I it is my is my content
not good enough am i is my voice not
good enough and I think about it every
time every time I see these emails every
time people ask me at conferences I
think about it I think about how sad I
am that I wasn't documented my life or
putting out content or doing the
askgaryvee show
during those five and a half years of
Wine Library TV so especially those 18
months when nobody was watching you know
the story that's never told is the story
that I was building Wine Library to a
huge company long before Wine Library TV
and that the first month that I did Wine
Library TV was the first time that Wine
Library had not grown 30% over the prior
years revenue so not only did I have the
patience to let it play itself out and
win it was a scenario where I was
actually losing money by being patient
many of the people that are going to
watch this video are not achieving what
they want and are lacking the patience
and think everything happens overnight
and that is coming at the cost of an
unhappy life or no loss financially just
loss in time just coming at the expense
of Angry Birds
house of cards marathons or the bowling
team or hanging out with friends and
having a beer or reading a magazine or
whatever the hell gets you off and
excited as a hobby it's coming at that
expense it's not coming at the expense
of actual money or something or pain or
you know it's coming up expense of a
luxury and so to me the the the insanity
really and that's what I'm going to you
know the this proportional
misunderstanding that there's not a
person that you can name
not one there's zero people that you can
name that had it happened overnight even
the nine year old Stevie Wonder six year
old Michael Jackson there were years of
work put in prior by their parents by
their uncles even with the greatest
talents even with LeBron you seem like
so young when he hit the scene guess
what he wasn't you know what even
playing basketball for 15 goddamn years
even though you all say to me like wow
you did it I didn't do it I did it when
I was 14 years old and 15 years old and
16 years old and 17 years old and 18
years old and 19 result and 20 years old
21 years old and 22 years old which were
all the years that every synched weekend
while my friends went to the Jersey
Shore and hooked up with girls while my
friends went fishing while my friends
hung out through around the football and
lived the leisure life every weekend
every every single weekend let me just
say one more time every weekend every
day from the day I got at a school to
the day I went back into school every
vacation day all of them not a good
amount of them every day from 7 a.m. to
back then 8 p.m. every day I was
learning the wine business
I was honing my craft to be good
salesman I was figuring out how to be an
operator I watched how my dad interacted
with his employees what I liked about it
what I didn't
I watched my cousin Bobby interact with
the employees I took what I liked from
it what I didn't I was 30 years old
before any of you ever saw me go show me
the videos on YouTube right now that
have me under 30
don't exist I was putting in the work
for half my life and from 15 to 30 where
I built an actual business I put in
actual work and so if you want to tell
me that every goddamn moment of my life
between 1530 is an overnight success and
knock yourself out but that is complete
[ __ ] and every one of you know it
and so when you email me that you've
started this thing that you have the
audacity to want it to be the rest of
your life
the audacity really the entitlement that
you think that you should be able to do
something that you love so much for the
rest of your life that makes you enough
money to be able to do it for the rest
of your life that you're giving up after
four months that you're giving up after
two years this matter of fact every
single person watching this video should
be trying for that moment for the rest
of their life period you might hit paid
out of 80 and cool then you can really
do exactly what you love from 80 to 100
my friends it is a gift this is a gift
to wake up in the morning and be able to
do what you want for the rest of your
life the way you do that is by becoming
a quote/unquote overnight success you
know the excuse that everybody uses the
deploy against somebody who's actually
put in work for the last decade and got
themselves into a position where they
can do something pretty rad that we all
think is cool and we all wish we could
do you know that thing the thing that
you say to yourself to make yourself
feel better about when you're laying in
bed and playing a goddamn game on your
phone instead of putting in the work to
achieve what you want nothing in life is
free nothing happens overnight it all
takes tons and tons of work and tons and
tons of talent and tons and tons of
serendipity but my friends luck
serendipity there's a forced culture
within that you know you don't just sit
in your room hoping and then something
lucky happens nobody just knocks on your
houses door and it says congratulations
you've been awarded this luck comes from
being in the right spot
I've been really lucky because I [ __ ]
bleed out of my eyes every day of my
life and work my face off get really
lucky when you have that 11:30 p.m.
meeting and we're the lucky thing
happened pretty cool since all you were
[ __ ] sleeping I was pretty lucky
weird that I scheduled that meeting
because I did a ton of things for 30
years that allowed me to even have that
meeting in the first place that gave me
the leverage to have that lucky thing to
happen
there's no overnight successes periods
they don't exist show me
leave a comment YouTube leave the name
explain to me tell me show me let me
know show me the overnight success
because I'll show you you justifying in
your brain something that is just not
true
period